never give up never underestimate the
power
you give yourself by believing
in you i realize that work
ethic equals results you can get
whatever you want as long as you help
enough people get what they want
hey guys welcome the bow show is back by
popular demand and we are so excited
we're launching the brand new
mastermind series and we're going to be
interviewing some of the most incredible
inspirational and motivational people on
the planet
and today i have someone who i hold very
close to my heart because not only have
they changed my life
they have changed the lives of dozens of
people i've known and then dozens of
other people i've met online and
literally i've built a community of
people who
this man has literally transformed them
so today my guest is the phenomenal wwe
hall of famer
ddp founder diamond dallas page how are
you dallas
bo it's good to be on here man it's good
to be on your show man to be
in a mastermind series with the people
that you
uh you have in your series is uh it's
pretty amazing so i'm honored and
humbled
to be uh a part of it what i love to do
is
use the power we have to spread good
to inspire people to change their lives
and you are someone who i believe has
done phenomenal and is known by millions
in around the world
but i want even more people to know not
just about your wrestling
not just about your gdp why but you as a
person your attitude
why you do what you do because that has
become
your fuel for your success and
you are a against the grain success
story you had everything against you
and you succeeded for instance if you
guys don't know
dallas became a professional wrestler at
wcw at the age of
35 that's when most people retire
and i'm not even 35 that's like me
deciding now
i'm gonna go in the ring and take on
roman reigns next year
but he did it he became the world
heavyweight champion three
times he was inducted to hall of fame
but
what's astounding is he used his
platform
and he deployed something which i think
is the most important thing in business
he deployed empathy
and realized there were people around
him who required the skills that he had
acquired so
dallas blew out his back and uh he's
going to tell you more about this but
through
a combination of calisthenics body
weight and yoga
bear with us he transformed his entire
life and now he teaches this it's one of
the most successful workout programs in
the world
there are literally millions of people
who owe their mobility and their
happiness to this man
and what we do on here is because this
is youtube
we're going to be talking about how one
of dallas's videos
was one of the first ever viral videos
that launched his company
the thinking behind it how it changed
the mistakes they made but also what
they did right
but most importantly we're going to hear
about someone whose
most important thing is to never give up
and
that's why we're so blessed to have you
here dallas so thank you for being here
oh it's my pleasure buddy so my first
question which i will dive into
is um why do you do what you do you know
i
um i love to watch
inspirational videos and i've been
listening to inspirational speakers
since i was a kid and i can remember
ziglar and he didn't say it like this
but
i always take what someone says
and i make it my own i don't care what
it is i'm gonna make it
you know my own way that i think it
sounds like
and what i took away from that
was you can get whatever you want
as long as you help enough people get
what they want
and i heard him say that
a version of that at 22 years old and it
just became a part of my mantra
um i tell people all the time who are
depressed
uh and you know crazy craziness that's
going on in
not our country but the world right now
but really crazy
in our country right now um
if you want to try to help deal with a
depression
help somebody help anybody i don't care
what it is
because that action
of helping someone else
makes them feel so good that they're
going to give that feeling back to you
and you feel much better about yourself
so
even as a a nightclub owner back before
i ever started professional wrestling
we would do the toys for tots drive and
we would do
different charity things and again
giving back to the greater good
made me feel really awesome i shared a
lot
of my journey which it never should have
happened
you know uh um jim ross called me the
greatest
overachiever ever um
you know i was the long shot of all time
when you start wrestling at 35
now here's what you have to understand
about wrestling i don't want to spoil
this for anybody
but wrestling is pre-determined
in other words the writers who
write the storylines write
who's going to win and not who's not
gonna win well
at 35 going from a manager to a wrestler
no one believed in me michael p.s hayes
who i was managing at the time
when i told him i was going to be start
going to train to wrestle
because they wouldn't let me manage
anymore mainly because
i was too over the top with the hair
and the wrap and the bling and the
diamond dolls and
i was taking too much attention away
from the wrestler but if i was wrestling
that would be a good thing so i thought
i had seven months left on my contract
i'm gonna go down here and i'm gonna
learn how to wrestle
michael p.s hayes fell down on his back
laughing
i mean like buckled him like it was such
a it was such a
ridiculous statement to him and looking
back
i guess he had a point imagine trying
out for the lakers or the
dallas cowboys or the yankees at 35 and
a half
not a chance but in professional
wrestling
it's different and being a character i'd
already had some groundwork at that
but they were just going to use me as a
buffer
to get other wrestlers over and
something i learned very early on as a
kid when i was 12 years old i got hit by
a car
i walked out in front of it it was my
fault my
knee it hit my right knee my face
bounced up the hood
and i flew 42 feet from the point of
impact at 12 years old i was like i
wouldn't say a prodigy but i was
incredible at football peewee football
papaya
pop warner football and hockey
and that took it all away they wouldn't
let me play because they were combat
sports
and they let me play basketball which i
sucked at and the bottom line is i
didn't make a team in seventh grade
because i hated i was playing football i
didn't need basketball
eighth grade i made the team but i sat
on the bench and i never sat on the
bench
that summer i swore that would never
happen to me again
and it's where i really learned about
learned about work ethic
and i went to the park that summer every
single day
i play from five to seven eight hours a
day
every day and my freshman year i started
we went undefeated by my sophomore year
i was starting varsity
i realized that work ethic equals
results
and that's what people didn't know about
me when i decided to become a wrestler
at 35
i was going to outwork everyone i was
going to be the first to come the last
league and it was going to take time
but i was going to make one believer at
a time
and it took me till i was 40 but the
second half of 40 years old
boom my career took off like a rocket
by the time that was 96 97 and 98
i'd headlined 12 or 13
either main event pay-per-views
or semi-main event pay-per-views
from obscurity and people couldn't
understand
because you have to go back to
understanding that someone decides
whether you win or lose
and in the beginning i couldn't make
anybody
believe it but i developed what we call
the end of the match as your finish move
like jake
the snake roberts had the greatest
finishing maneuver of the 80s
it was the ddt jake was phenomenal on
the mic
in the ring and had a finish i was
phenomenal
on the mic when given the opportunity my
ring work was getting better
but when it came to my finish
i developed the finish that randy orton
uses today
the rko before it was the rko it was a
diamond cutter
and it exploded buildings
being like when i would hit that finish
out of nowhere
it blew people it like
exploded them out of their seats and
what i did was i created a sign
which was a diamond cutter sign so even
though i was
when they let me beat people they were
nobodies
this applies to everything no matter who
you work with
no matter who you're around if you make
them
look better if you make them look the
best they've
ever been that makes you look
incredible and i would go out there and
work
wrestling matches with guys that weren't
as good as me
and were on the bottom of the the barrel
but i'd go out there and make them look
like ric flair
i would give him some kind of spot and a
match and
oh my god he's going to beat him he's
going to beat him because i'm a bad guy
at the time
and everybody wants to see the bad guy
lose and so
i would finally like slip on a banana
peel and then
boom boom boom boom and then the crowd
would be up
and then he'd go to do something to me
and i'd turn in a diamond cutter
and whoa in the beginning it shut people
down
but then they started to pop pop pop to
where
yeah there's a there's a youtube up
called diamond cutters on everyone
you can see how the diamond cutter
explodes with
people as you move through it but when i
would hit my finish
and we had 20 000 people in the arenas
at that time
the whole left side of the building
would throw up the diamond cutter now
i'm still a bad guy
i'm not a good guy but the
people made they wanted the cheer
for you know they wanted to chat ddp
and it was because when i walk out
of my entrance and throw this over my
head
a thousand people started to do it then
five thousand
and then twenty thousand and they
couldn't deny me
and i would not be denied
my work ethic would shine through and
what i really found and this is
important in life
my real first name before i changed it
to dallas page was paige joseph
faulkenberg
and what i found as my career was
starting to build a little bit of
momentum
that everyone started putting over my
work ethic
and just how diligently i would not only
work in the ring but
before and after and studying films
almost like
a uh peyton you know uh you're one of
those
or tom brady like these guys study study
study that's what i did
and other wrestlers started talking
about it in interviews
and i realized once paige joseph
faulkenberg
stopped trying to be this bigger than
life
over-the-top wrestling persona diamond
dallas page
and diamond dallas paige started to take
on the characteristics
of paige joseph fuckerberg
man my career took off like a rocket so
work ethic inside my hall of fame reign
the inscription says work ethic
equals dreams explanation point
ddp that's powerful because
i know personally you're right because
my mantra when i had nothing
was you may be smarter than me you may
be bigger than me you may be stronger
but you will never outwork me ever i
will die before you outwork me
and i took that work ethic uh all the
way with me and now i'm doing what i do
but the cool thing is just because
you've
got to a place of comfort doesn't mean
you take your foot off the gas and i
still pride myself on my work ethic
and i see that you're the same and so i
think a really valuable lesson
a valuable lesson there is when
it's it's the thing you said about one
person at a time and so many people are
trying to
some people are trying to make it big
which is just nonsense but people who
actually want to do it because they love
it
right that's how you do it and if if you
do have a dream
and it's in here and you want to just
project it to the world
if the world's not listening guys just
listen just rewind this entire bit and
just listen to what dallas said again
one person at a time would throw up the
diamond cutter just one more
and then two and literally you got 20
000 and then that's over 10 years
so i love it let me let me tell you
something here beau too
the only reason it really got over
was because i did the study work
on the back end like i would throw it up
and then i'd bring it right down and i
was looking i didn't see anybody do it
and then one day because i filmed every
single match
i feel i'm the first guy to ever ice
his body in professional wrestling i'd
ice my knees
and my back before maybe for hours after
a match
and people go like what are you doing
what are you doing i'm
holding back the hands of time i'm
taking down inflammation
but uh i filmed every single
match and the guys would laugh at me
and bust my chops and look on how many
matches are up on youtube today
there's millions from all over the world
from japan
mexico and you know the uk and
you know uh canada i mean australia
guys who are wrestling their videos are
everywhere i was filming
every match back then and one day
after i've been sitting there and
watching
you know the the crowd and when i did
this
i saw people starting to do this in
their seats
but i'd already brought it down
and i went hmm i didn't leave it there
long enough
so when i finally got to i would throw
it up over my head high
and i literally would count to myself
three
two one bang
that gave time for people to
not just throw it up but to stand up
with me
so you oh it's so
important to understand
you never know who's watching like
you never know who's listening and
watching
what you're doing you know i i often
tell people
it's not about who you know or who knows
you
it's about who's willing to say they
know you
who's willing to pick up the phone and
say listen bro
you got to use bo because he's got this
thing he's doing he's going to make it
on netflix and i'm telling you
you want to do this interview with him
because he's got great heart
he's super into what he's doing he loves
what he's doing and he's going to get
out the best in you
like that's what it takes who's willing
to put their name on the line for you
and what would happen for me in
wrestling
is it started with jake the snake
roberts and i could
do a two-hour podcast just on me and
jake
uh maybe five hour podcast
but he was the first one the guy that i
looked up
to the most as a wrestler who could talk
who could work who just had
all of it and
when he told me in 1993
that i was going to be one of the
biggest names in the business
it was the beginning of me starting to
believe it i always tell people
never underestimate the power
you give by believing in them
i brought that up when i introduced i
inducted
jake into the hall of fame on my 58th
birthday in uh uh
in new orleans i believe it was i
inducted him
into the hall of fame and i had this
amazing speech written
and a lot i always believe in
preparation and improvisation
and at some point i said that right at a
point i never said
it before i said never underestimate the
power
you give someone by believing in them
more importantly never underestimate the
power
you give yourself by believing
in you because there's only one person i
had to believe in you bo
that was you and you proved yourself
right
i think it's fate because evan
carmichael who's on this channel
he has something called his one word and
he it's basically a word that
uh basically encapsulates everything in
their life
and it's what is their north star and
evan's word in which he's
garnered millions of followers out of
and changed our lives it's the word
belief
he believes you should believe in
yourself i don't know which way to go
because there's so much problems here
i'm so excited speaking to you because
i i'm so happy i'm hoping this will be
one of those things that we put online
and there's just so much gold that
you're gonna have to keep going back and
come forward but i'm gonna take the time
to
dig this gold right now two things you
just
touched on were when for instance when
uh you were
cultivating the diamond cutter and you
were putting it down too early
because you did the extra work and and
you did
the kind of you're due diligence 99.99
of people would have done it and then
said well
my strategy for whatever i'm doing isn't
working so i'm gonna change
but you took a different path being like
wait let's just dive a little deeper
and it can sometimes be painful when
you're looking at going okay why am i
failing and i think a lot of people have
fear of failure
i'm addicted to looking at where i'm
messing up because i'm like oh my god
i'm gonna find something great
so a really valuable lesson guys here
which dallas has just shown is
you might still be doing the right thing
you just might need that one
percent adjustment uh tony robbins has a
great line about if you
set two ships off from ireland uh on the
same path but one degree difference
one's going to end up in
south america and the other is going to
end up in canada there's one degree
difference
right right isn't that incredible and so
you took that
change and changed your finisher the
diamond cutter by one percent
and it changed your life uh but another
thing
another thing that i'd love for people
to know about is
i understand you've got incredible work
ethic and you work harder than anyone
and you're gonna go and get it
authentically and honestly what were
those times like
when it wasn't quite going right and you
questioned yourself what was the
conversation
well you know i'm going to share this
with you when we get off the phone
uh get off this interview i want to send
you
my newest documentary you know my first
documentary was the resurrection
of jake the snake which was rave reviews
the second one that'll be out this year
it's called
relentless and it's from me blowing out
my back
and telling me my career is over
at 42 right when i just signed
a multi-million dollar three-year deal
and now i've ruptured my l4 and l5 so
badly
that three spine specialists are telling
my career is
over and at that point man
you know you know it it tore me down
it tore me down i'll i'll tell you the
first time
which was the wrestling time
no one believed in me until jake
and then after that the guy who made me
without
dusty rhodes there is no diamond dallas
page
i got dusty to believe in me and then i
got
hulk hogan to believe in me none of this
that i brought to them and asked them
they came to me
and said this and when hulk said it to
me it was in 1994
and i got to be honest man i've there
was times where i was thinking
this this isn't working you know i i got
to get get my release i got to go the
wwf
at the time now wwe um
there's no one who you know is is making
anything happen here
don't don't believe in me to give me the
opportunity
and hulk i was on a tour with him
in germany i'm the first match i'm the
curtain jerker i'm at the bottom of the
card
and when i walk through the curtain
after day five we got
20 days on the road we're going to
wrestle 17 of them
we work five days in a row i come
through the curtain
hulk grabs me pulls me over he says to
me
how are you doing it i'm like am i doing
doing what hulk he goes how are you
getting so much better
i go wow thanks bro i go uh and
then he answers the question for me he
goes this is what they're doing with you
right
because i hardly ever see you on tv but
when i do see you on tv
you've got some new move you pop up you
get the people involved
he says so this is what they're doing
with you they're putting you on the road
so you can learn your craft
and i said well no um i haven't been on
the road in four months
the only reason i'm on the road right
now
is because my last real name before i
change it
was faulkenberg and the krauts love the
germans
and i got smoking hot white that walks
me to the ring
i said that's the reason i'm on the card
he goes well how the hell are you doing
it
if you're not you're not training you
know you're not
getting learning your crap i said well i
i am learning my craft i
uh not i'd rather be on the road but
i go to the power plant every day and i
learn
to teach the younger guys because every
day i need to be in the ring
i need to be the first one there i need
to be the last one to leave i said
i'm teaching the young guys and what i
figured out is the more you
teach someone this applies to everything
the more you teach someone the more you
learn
the more you learn the better you get
and
obviously you know for you to come up to
me hope and he said
whatever it is i don't care what
whatever he didn't really understand
that
because he came up differently than i
did there was just all these territories
when he came up
that wrestling was all over the world
and
uh before wwf swallowed everything up
and he said whatever you're doing you
keep doing it he goes because it's not
this year or next year the year after
but somewhere down the line you have the
ability
to draw big money with me and he walked
away
and i thought wow
did hulk hogan just say that to me that
he watched my matches and i'm at the
bottom of the card
did he say that we could really draw
money together
i started to manifest that daily
it became another part of the mantra i
tell everybody
just don't think it ink it like
write it down burn it into your brain
and uh
four years later now i don't know if
it's over in your country but right now
in our country
michael jordan's bulls the chicago bulls
the last dance it's the biggest
it's all over the i think it's all over
the world it's one of the
probably the best documentaries ever but
the entire documentary is about 1998
and there hits a point in the
documentary where they talk about rodman
not showing up the practice in the
playoff
finals and rodman
shows up with hulk hogan as i'm cutting
an interview
and hit me with the chairs
they show that on i got a
cameo you know towards the end of
episode 10
but i'm the reason why he wasn't at
practice
really hulk was a reason why but it was
about to shoot the angle the beginning
of the angle with me and
yo later would be malone so they shoot
the angle hit me with the chairs makes
espn the whole thing and
later after the series is over rodman
and hogan are on the tonight show
and me and malone come in from the wings
throw down the chairs
and shoot our angle on the tonight show
not the wrestling show the tonight show
and it exploded i mean like you said
i i i have my goals and as
lofty as they are i somehow continue
to hit him i always tell people don't
just
shoot you know don't be afraid to shoot
for the stars
because a lot of times if you put the
work in now those are those
very important words if you put
the work in those six words
if you continue to put the work and if
you don't quit if you believe
in yourself at some point
you might hit a little bit under the
goal or to the left or to the right
a lot of times in this scenario exactly
i shot so far past that goal that i
would
never even believed it if i would have
thought about in the beginning
but hulk said we could draw huge money
together
that tag team match and hulk and i drew
a lot of money together
but that first tag team match
we were the second
highest grossing pay-per-view in the
history
of wcw and one of the top
10 biggest drawing cards of all time
in all of wrestling and again i go back
to manifesting
that dream to make it a reality
but putting the work in and
never stop believing you know that's the
biggest thing
so but over that period i second guess
myself like with ddp yoga
and a lot of people have been really
kind of blown away
the second act that i've been able to
have
but the second act with my whole ddpy
program is because we put together such
an
amazing team i didn't do any of this by
myself
a lot of stuff i have done to inspire
people
and that work with them and like that's
the part i do
you know i do the part like making the
cake
and then my business partner steve you
comes in and then he tells the story
because it's being able to tell the
story
is where you take the magic and
a great example we were talking about
arthur borman earlier
who's the guy who put really
it really put what i was doing on the
map
and she put all the you know the bells
and whistles in there
that made you connect to
that video that made you care
that that that made you want to share it
with someone else
and that's the magic and when it started
to go viral
and i didn't even know what viral meant
in 2012
be honest steve calls me up and he said
i just text you something read it
and i read on the text it says it's a
tweet
and it says stop what you're doing right
now
and witness real magic
it was from david copperfield that's
when i'm getting on a plane and flying
to nashville from la i get to
nashville steve sends me another tweet
and this one says you want to be
inspired
this is one of the most inspiring videos
i've ever seen starts out slow
well worth the wait tony robbins
i was like wow you know
i always tell people that i am the new
jack lelane meets tony robbins meets
straight richard simmons
see i know a little more about the
arthur boorman story video and i think
this is going to be so important to
share with everyone that
the reason the arthur bohrman video is
so successful is it's a case of
of authentic marketing so you were sent
you were talking about the message
and if correct me if i'm wrong but
wasn't there a video
before that had a lot more ddp yoga or i
think his yrg
logo so by you taking that out and
focusing on the story
you actually created empathy compassion
and connectivity
with an audience you didn't even know
you had and that
exploded is that correct yeah and it was
steve it was again it was steve who uh
he redid the video and he sent it to me
and i was like wow this is powerful i
call them up
i go bro because by the time we change
the company from yrg
to ddp yoga i said you didn't put ddp
yoga in there
he goes yeah he goes um but
you know i read this book and he only
actually read the first
four or five chapters and it was how to
get a video to go viral
and number one thing it cannot be an ad
you know it cannot be an a now if it's a
funny ad
that's different you know but
people will you know they won't they
won't share it if it's if they feel it's
an ad
and i go you go so do you want to do a
commercial
or do you want to inspire people i said
well let's inspire people and i hung up
the phone and i watched it a couple of
more times
i called him back and said bro you
called me a yogi in this
i don't want to be i'm not i'm the anti
yogi yogi you know
and he's like hey yeah how many yoga
studios are gonna put this up on the
wall
you still do a form of yoga it's a form
of yoga
for people who wouldn't be caught dead
doing yoga
but it's still like you use a lot of
yoga stuff so do you want to have that
in there or
you know i said okay and what i learned
and being able to laugh about it today
because i still have things
that i want to do my way and when i
really want to focus on that
we normally hit pretty good but most
times i have found
that steve's i let him tell the story so
if it gets to me not saying exactly the
way we need it because it's got to be
short little clips
i'll just let them direct me because
it's we both speak from the heart
you know we say what we really feel now
say it so people understand it
and every time it you know it's magic
and uh you know we've been so blessed
you know we were on um shark tank years
ago
and five years ago six years ago and uh
mr wonderful back then there was no
really online workouts
we were getting ready we already started
it started to do the you know the back
end work
for our app and uh there was really none
of that back then
and mr wonderful said you know
it's really hard today you know
to be a a fitness company that makes
money like beachbody who does you know
from p90x insanity to you know whatever
they've got a million different workouts
that they sell and do
they're they're a huge company and then
gaium who's a yoga company they're a
huge company
um but most of the time people who
develop
dvds like we originally started with
today it's everything from cooking shows
to motivation
monday monday motivational mondays like
everything doing
inspirable people to keep themselves
going and and
be able to track their uh from their
size their pictures the weight the
measurements
it's all that stuff so make some whoa i
can
keep growing from this and stay inspired
but back then
it was just dvds and he said
you could fill the superdome with all
the
dvds that athletes and celebrities have
done
who never could make anything no how are
you guys making the money
and steve said we inspire people
and wonderful one yeah yeah that's great
that's great but how do you make the
money
i said bro we inspire people that's what
we do
and you know that's the magic to me i'm
so lucky man i
i interview and i connect and i have
dinner and with
so many people in this industry of
trying to make people better and
i'm lucky that i know a lot of the best
however
there are a lot of people who the
inspiration part is their secondary goal
and it's tragic to see and it br
they have like a bright flame but they
burn out really fast so i think part of
your longevity is that you actually
you actually care and what i find
amazing
so if arthur bormann was 2012 i was
looking at your evolution going okay so
yeah most people they're always typing
in okay i want 2020 i want
2019. i don't care about 2012. what i
found amazing was
you have an actually more successful
video now by
that's heinz what's amazing about him
is he has the viral video aspect
but through connectivity through your
facebook groups and everything
he is an active member promoting the
joy that you've given him and the power
you've empowered him with
so therefore people feel connected to
you on a deeper level because they're
connecting with the result and i think
in this day and age it really shows that
community is one of the best ways to
build
a movement and to build business but you
got to do it from the heart so guys
if you're doing something because you
think you're going to get rich if you're
doing it because you think you're going
to get laid
don't do it if you want to get laid do
ddpy
it'll work but you got it it's got to
come from the heart
and i know it changed my life
and i just i'm that's why i bring these
masters on here
so they can like a sledgehammer crack
you in the skull with that beautiful
piece of message saying
do it because you love it and as you've
seen here guys if you check out i'm
going to link the arthur boorman video
in the
in the actual description of this so you
can see
what an actual transformation it is and
then you're going to go into a bit of a
youtube
rabbit hole because you're going to
click the next one and the next one and
before you know
four hours you're going to be throwing
diamond cutters around your living room
your parents are going to be mad at you
it's funny because i always tell people
find something you love to do
and then figure out a way to make money
in it now
in this movie relentless that uh you
know steve is
the executive producer with me on um
in this movie this documentary like
we get into like the downs
like because there it wasn't all up it's
like it
it it was only upset little peaks and
then it would go back down
where you got to believe in yourself and
again i
love what i was doing and i wouldn't
take anybody else's money but my own
and i had 548 000
in this company before
i made a dime and that was eight
years long before i made a dime
you know and actually took any money uh
for doing anything and along the way
when i would get hit that wall
and i'd be like god did i just piss away
200 300 400 000 plus dollars
and then i you know by that time i had
arthur's video and i just played again
and it's the one that i edited with his
son and it was pretty good
wasn't what steve did but it was pretty
good um
the bottom line is is that i would see
it
and then i'd get like an email from
someone i have no idea how they got my
email
today it's on twitter and instagram and
you know and facebook and all that so
people can send me anything
but i get some letter from someone
thanking me
for great creating a program that
someone who is
an invalid who is broken down
can do to a workout
that is the psycho extreme stuff
so literally it goes from to everyone
that can do the program at their own
level
ddpy meets you where you
are and i would get that and man that
would like
choke me up and then i'd get on the map
you know
and then i'd have a workout and boom i'd
be
i'd be charged and ready to go again
because one of the things people don't
understand
all you got to do is get on the map or
get you know walk around your block do
something
do something that um
that's where you have to use energy
you know with weights whatever it is
because
exercise helps reduce stress
and then once you get refocused on what
you believe in
then use that and then boom you keep on
going you know
that's what our movie relentless is all
about
you know what like we can talk for hours
and i'm sure
in the future we will because i would
love an entire interview with you just
about the importance of taking care of
your physical body
to become successful in whatever you do
in life because i think some people eat
junk they work themselves into the
ground
and they classify themselves as busy and
that they don't have the time to work
out as a badge of honor which i think is
just
but it is that's another one but before
we go
before we go to our final question
something i want to do because i want to
give back because not only have you
changed my life with your fitness
because
i i know most of the beachbody people
personally and i'm very
lucky too i've actually spoken in the
united states on a motivational tour
with some of them
but your app your routine
the accessibility and the compassion
that you have even though it's
pre-recorded and it's archived
compassion bleeds through it and no
matter who you are
it can change your life and i can
promise you dozens of people i know
have been buying it left right and
center not just to to to say look i've
got the app
it's making a difference in their lives
they're losing weight they're more
flexible they're out of pain
so what i want to do is in the comments
of this video tell me
what you took away from this interview
and i will pick one of you and i'm going
to buy you a
an entire year's subscription to ddpy
and it's on me because i want you to
experience this incredible magic
and i think it's so important
the connection between health and
fitness
and the success of your life that if i
can just be a small push in the
direction for the right person
that's what i want to give back so for
the last
question uh which i normally end with is
similar to what evan said we all have a
word evan's word is believe
he wants to make people believe he
believes in himself the belief
mindset is what creates miracles for me
my one word is incredible
i want an incredible life surrounded by
incredible people i do incredible things
and i do
not accept anything less than incredible
do you have a word uh it might be the
thing on your shirt right now
do you have a word
that you would say encapsulates your
being that would be your north star
relentless
that you can't relentless says it all
you know uh
never give up you know believe it
it encompasses from never giving up to
believe in yourself
to put the work in you know relentless
says so many things to me
to come up with that title for it steve
and i went back and forth
like what what is the most powerful
thing that we can
say that will give what this documentary
is all about
and it was relentless and
i think that uh when you are relentless
you understand that to do it
you can't give up because you're
relentless
you you know that you're uh you got to
put the work in
you know i just got to keep you i got to
stay positive i've got to be
unstoppable they to me they're all
connected together you know and one of
the things you said earlier you said
about the community that we've built
one of the things we have that is
completely organic
um and it was a a buddy of mine who
started it who started i became a buddy
of mine
because he did my program uh and his
name was we called the bad
the boston bad boy chris and uh
chris gabriano he started originally and
then at some point
he would also do something else and he
gave it to a couple of other guys and
one is a one guy who became an
instructor in canada
and it's ddp yoga one word it's on
facebook
it's for members there's like 47 000
people on it
that are the most active group of people
that i've ever seen all helping
each other like there is a uh
no judge like what's the wall stuff you
know because it's the internet
someone will come in there and you know
have to spout some negative stuff
and eventually it'll get to me and if it
does
i go right to them and i'm like dude
what are you doing
like that's not what this site's about
this site's about helping each other
about
you know you know giving someone you
know a pat on the back when they need it
giving someone
you know the understanding of just kind
of sometimes just got to keep putting
one foot in front of the other
and men and women because we develop
like six pictures and everything's on
the app the
pictures the weight the measurement
blood sugar
blood pressure a1c all these numbers
and pictures so you can see the numbers
come down which
makes your confidence build up and
on this facebook page i have seen
pictures of women
and men that there is no way before they
heard of this program that they ever
would have put those six have the the
guts
to put those six pictures up there and
they are so
whenever i see it i'm like i am so proud
of you
because that's the beginning of it look
seeing the pitch taking the pictures
and then looking at them one of the
girls i helped years ago
named stacy morris plus 185 pounds
in 18 months she'd lost she'd been over
300 pounds twice in her life
and gained it all back when i got with
her she was 3 45.
when she took the pictures she
emailed me i cried
for three days and the pictures i saw
the one she sent me they weren't the
pictures she took
these ones in a baggy t-shirt i'm
looking at them and going
why would she cry over these pictures
but once she got to her goals
and she had pictures she was proud of
she put those pictures that made her cry
up and one to another and you were like
wow that's the same chick she looked
like maro monroe now
you know so i always tell people you've
got to take those pictures
you've got to do the measurements you've
got to know your weight you've got to
have
goals because you need to see where you
started
to where you are today and every month
we tell you to put up new pictures
and new measurements a new art so now
you can put you can look at day one
month three months seven ten eighteen
months later whatever it is
you can see where you are and it's a
feeling of accomplishment
and starting to build that confidence
i tell people all the time don't listen
to a word i say about my program
go on twitter real ddp or at
ddp yoga or instagram diamond dolls page
or
ddp yoga or just go to one word ddp yoga
on facebook look at that member site
read what people write
ask them questions they'll tell you
it's pretty amazing you have one of the
most authentic fan bases i've seen
that's not
trying just to um like
motivate each other but they're lifting
each other up and one thing that i think
one of the most powerful things that we
have
that's the kind of the catalyst for
growth which most people are afraid of
is
people feel it's a safe space to be
vulnerable and you get some incredible
stories on there i'm a member i love it
i try and support as much as i can
because i know that i've had dark times
and
just having one person reach out and
show some compassion show a bit of
kindness
has changed the direction of my life and
so i think what you're doing there is
beautiful
and this is so exciting because so many
people are going to start
exploring you now and just their lives
are going to change and
people who are they might be eating
doritos watching their youtube and
thinking
their business going and going you know
what damn the doritos we're doing this
um so dallas thank you so much
and i've never actually had someone tell
me their one word
and make me question mine because you
and i are i think are
kindred spirits in a way of that work
ethic relentlessness and
relentless relentless vibrated quite
nicely within me
so i've got i've got my uh my one word
bracelet it's got incredible on it but
i might have to chisel relentless into
there so thank you so much
guys all the links are going to be below
check out
i i don't know if you've got any more
holiday because
probably covered 19 is going to be to an
end but if it's still here by the time
you're watching this you've got time to
explore
hours of dallas's content on youtube and
everything get the app get the dvds
but most importantly rewind this there's
so much gold in here that he said that i
couldn't even question because we moved
on so fast
and i promise you guys we're going to
come back for another mastermind this is
just the beginning
so dallas thank you so much for your
time today and we'll see you guys for
another bow show soon
if you want to change your life in 30
days check out my free training right
here below or if you want to see the
beau show episode with gary vaynerchuk
check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
i'll see you there